I can't wait to see Sonic
I'm gonna say how much time you get to
share the screen with Jim and what were
those days on set like they were they're
amazing you know there's there's a good
portion movie where we weird together
and I'm sorry I mean he's a legend and
yes sharing scenes with him
in addition to being on so much I have
to ask you did you ever think that
Westworld was going to be what it is you
don't expect it to happen
no one knows they're going to be a part
of something you know a massive hit
but sometimes from the get-go number of
people that were involved in sellers you
see the writing it had all the makings
of a head
we're excited to this let it try to be
shooting obviously this year you're
shooting again soon have you seen the
second season sorry have you seen the
second season yes I know I have but I
was going to say that maybe that show
anything is possible at the wrong end of
a barrel with as I said with that show
it could be anything
I mean who ever thought Anthony Hopkins
is gonna be you know that's what I mean
what's coming up for you after obviously
promoting something
sharp black comedies another cool thing
to be part of
very different from this obviously those
are kind of the two I'm focusing on
right now my last thing for you about
Sonic did you ever think playing all
those video games as a kid was going to
lead to research for the movie I play
the expert video games too you know and
you never young you don't think it's
always a great fan to be able to help
Shepherd that to the big screen let me